today uh we are the next talk is going
to be Hannah Eisenman uh she is studying
data visualization at Cooney she'll be
presenting a talk called plotting with
Matt
pob um we'll be going through uh the
tutorial on uh creating publication
quality um animated and interactive
figures using Matt
po yeah hello folks I'm Hana um I'm M
live maintainer since 2016 I'm the
community manager um and I'm a glad
student studying FS so that's just my
point of view for this talk my goal here
because this is only 90 minutes is I'm
there's only so much you can teach right
um my get my goal here very much is to
get you familiar with the map object
model because if you can understand a
map live object model it opens up the
door to kind of do what whatever you
want with a library so once you
understand that um and that's kind of
where the bulk of the static work is
going to be and then when we go into
animated it'll be more of like okay now
how do we change that object those
objects to update so we can animate
things and then how do we and it
interactive is more of the same and
that's again why the focus of this talk
will be
explaining the map of object model
because the object model is also the
conceptual underpinning so how many of
you have used
ggot how many of you are very confused
when you move from ggot to
molp yes this is because GG plot was
designed by statisticians for
statistical data and it uses the
language of academic visualization in
its paradigms map Li was designed by
scientists coming from a computer
Graphics framework and so it's using a
language of computer Graphics in a lot
of how it thinks about the visualization
how it thinks about how you change
things um and so that's where and so
like said what I wanted to hear is help
you learn to speak M um there there's a
lot the V is here it has um semi blank
out notebooks on the top level Solutions
in the um in a
folder it's should work on code spaces
cuz the repo's in there but also so the
first two notebooks all they use is
regular mot Li so they will work in any
environment where you can put map poot
Li
um and then the last notebook is the
only one that needs another and what
another couple of libraries for and
faster um easy
interactivity
so um how many of you all are set
up
yeah okay you all set up so can I give
you all like two three minutes to have a
working Mook and I will say I understand
if some of you don't want to like follow
along um typing and you just want to
watch this totally understandable again
it's 90 minutes my goal here is
primarily to help you understand how map
our Li things of things so that you can
go into our documentation and find the
thing and also so you can learn kind of
what the library does um I may this
earlier but um if you if you decide to
if you're not sure if you're going to
stay or not I ask that you sit in the
back just that you don't
um interrupt the flow of folks who are
in front of
you
okay
so folks ready to get
started I way tooo much going
on okay so what we're going to do for
this tutorial is we're going to use the
Palmer penguin data set the reason we
use the Palmer penguin data set in this
tutorial is because it is a
multivariate data set that is small
enough to be usable in a tutorial and
not too small that it's
trivial um and and it's multivalued we
can show kind of the visualization
challenges that come with trying to
visualize different types of data types
um it's also now being common used in
education the pal penguin data set is a
data set of the actually how many of you
have seen
it
already some of you yeah it's a DAT set
that has shows you the characteristics
of male and female Penguins on uh of
three
species on three
islands
okay so the first step of any and this
is way too small and I know this is way
too small you no one's seeing this code
right
which my goal here is that you use your
time well if you cannot see something or
cannot hear something or cannot
understand what I am saying please let
me know find a paper tothor it me you
know just get my
attention because you trying to stare at
the screen isn't going to help anyone
but I will say again the notebooks are
in the Vost you can follow along there
if that is more accessible to
you so step
one oh I know these
should um I should def this
beforehand um to just like hide all my
tool bars does anyone remember how you
can hide all of
them no okay I'll do the other way
um let's open the and a browser that
doesn't have this much on the
top okay so you're all clearly letting
my Bowser preferences right now and that
juper hates Jupiter hates it okay never
mind let's not waste too much time with
that um so the first thing we do is we
import our libraries we import pandas
SPD we import um
M.T this is the convention you will find
everywhere um mostly so we're going to
stick with it so that basically you can
read all of this code interchangeably
we're using pandas why do you think
we're using pandas the data is in CSV
file yeah the yep p is what you need use
to VI a CSD file what's the command
we're going to
use what command that we using in in
pandas vtsb there's a there used to be a
staff right 90% of cattle entries had me
tsv only thing they from pandas but um
so we load out we load our libraries we
load in our data set we get when
actually load and I said this but of
course what
this I do something
terrible it to
me oh because I'm in the wrong notebook
of course I am
um okay load the data load the data set
we do GF info the reason is is because
we want to know what the data types are
of our valuable trying to plot them
because that is where you will run into
lots of
issues
um and here I'm cleaning it just to make
again for the sake of the tutorial
working cleanly for for the sake of not
having spend 30 minutes on dealing with
missing data in the
tutorial um so the first thing we do in
map live is we create a figure and we
create an axis what are these things the
best way to think about it is that
figure it's like the Whiteboard you see
my giant drawing space I can put all the
things on it so that's the mapol figure
it is the campus it is the drawing area
it is the thing you will layer all of
your visualizations on so big thing
figure now what's this thing with
numbers that is the axis the so the
figure is an object and then the axis
are objects that go inside F and the
axis is the plotting region or the
visual unit like if you think of a chart
like think of a
visualization like if you think of a
visualization
um I'm looking for white course yeah
that's over that side yeah okay if I've
got this
visualization
how many charts is
that one
one how many charts is
that when you think about this like for
paper publication is that do you think
of that as one or
two
one what about if I then put this on
it
Bill one what do all of these visual Lum
these Char types visual idioms visual
algorithms pick your name for these
things what do all of these have in
common the same axis right so this is
plot one this is plot two this is plot B
I have question if I start
here
and I am starting with this right is
that the same
chart what do these two things have in
common axis so in map Li the axis object
ax ax e s is the plotting region is the
plotting region region associated with
one set of X and Y or polar axis it is
the plotted plotting region where
everything goes to that same set of
coordinate
transforms
so and that's important because that's
how you think about like if I want to PL
multiple on the same axis and same thing
right if you do any visuals right do
they get do they get do all these plots
go on the same Axis or do they start go
into seate on so amp Li that is the axis
object and and aess object and how many
axess do I have on on this
board does it look like do you think
there's a limit to how many axis I can
fit on this
board same thing in M lip I mean the
memory will die first but axes go on a
figure object they go on that canvas you
can kind of layer as many as you need
within you know printable computable
leader um Reon now because we don't like
anybody does anybody know what this is
called how do we spell
this yep and that's live these are the
axis objects axis and this whole thing
is the access object
axes again I
said um no actually we love how uses of
course this is because of course in
these are called the absis and that is
called the abis and no one thought of no
one was really considering how hard that
is to actually
communicate um vocally you know
instructionally to
users so abis have axes and we plot data
on them all of the would you believe me
if I told you all of these things have
the same parent
object
yeah um
so in math. live the parent
object is the oh here I can actually
tell you this way here's typ fig
actually this probably will not tell let
me see if
this um typ
that
so okay then um these are all artist
objects in map live the base object is
called the arst and that is the
parent object for any visual element you
see rendered in that graph or in that
figure it is the axis lines it is the
plots it is the figure itself it is the
canv it is the axis it is lables it is
Tick all of those things are
children of the artist class and the
reason this is important is because
because again it's like what can you do
with the visual elements you can do
anything that is a method on either that
child class or that parent class and I'm
stressing again and again that it's all
everything is an object it is very very
objectoriented in terms of how you work
with a in play map Li
so and I say this let's do the first
thing right we are going to add an image
here we're going to add our plot of our
histogram right this plot not Matrix
this is the flipper length the building
these are three columns in our data in
our data set the command is p color mesh
where P color mesh
is um a heat map type algorithm that
takes each element in the each um cell
in your Matrix and it colors it and the
reason I'm using p color mesh is not
like in show or match show is because
peor mesh will also stretch in this case
it's a three column of it and I can show
you what I mean by that um if I do IM
show see no other strch very annoying
um and this is going to be
my let me show you um
I'm going to take one side trip to
map.org
to show you our plot Gallery if you want
a brief overview of what we
visualizations we support types we
support there these aren't all of the
ones we support but we try to kind of
have a comprehensive listing and a to
both have comprehensive listing and to
kind of linking to other simp related
methods that we don't list here but but
we'll do uh you know like it's this
method but with the valubles a little
bit
different so that is
our way that that is our
um plot type Gallery um and I will and
again going to keep testing this if it's
not in there we can still make it it
just takes a little bit more work
because then you have to work with um
the
build those charts are all made up of
artist and you can go into those
directly to make the visualizations you
need if you're looking for more
theoretical if you're either using uh
visualization that type that we do not
have or you're you know a researcher
developing a new visualization type um I
will say also lots of people build third
party packages on top of mapa where they
Implement to me the set of
visualizations
so okay the thing I've been on about
about artist this this is where it comes
in handy we want to get a cable right
cuz we haven't labeled anything in our
visualization because we haven't labeled
anything do you know what any of this
means do you know what the color means
no right so what we want to do is we
want to add a color B the way we can do
that
is we grab the image which is we grab
the object out of that plot which is the
image artist which is in this case a
scal of mcable type artist and that
artist we can pass into the color Bar
Method to then make a color bar that
pulls its colors and it's labeling from
that image so that's kind of how your IM
your information just passes
through um again we'll read it from
somewhere else and this is how you
ensure that your color box stays sync to
your image as you change it because the
thing is is things are
Dynamic I
can I can decide the reasons I don't
quite remember um I can decide that
instead this is my data for that
image okay I forgot the exact method of
course don't do things live um but you
can change things on demand dynamically
and this is what lets you that color
ball be what of it
um
okay
so fun Fe feature we have we can if
you're losing Jupiter we can print you a
copy of the color bars in the notebook
as you need this is kind of a quick way
to scan color BL see if you like them um
how cuz do you want to try different
colors what kind of colors would you
want to see on
this
red what the
red that a color M to
Red um and basically you can use any
string name for a color map as long as
it's in our registry so now we we pass
that in as an argument to be color mesh
and now we have a red table of
properties of our
P if we don't like how these things are
getting mapped well like I don't want a
25 to 250 right I want it shorter and
map all that's what's called the
normalization system so the
normalization system is how we go from
value to from data value to a 0 to one
scale that we'll look into the color
look of table to get out the
color so what we can do here is we can
most of these methods will let me just
do What's called the built-in
normalization which is a setting the mid
and the max for that me mapping and
that's what I can do here just as
passing in you can also do more advanced
things with Norm objects and I'll show a
little example of that later
but um again you can kind of customize
as
needed so how do we label things again
remember how I said everything is an
object well access object
like the axis and like the color bar
axis have all of these special methods
on them that let you set things so you
can set the tick you can set the labels
and with using methods named set X tick
set label so here we
label the axis and we label the tips so
that now I can know which column is
which the bill length build flip
length um color B and I have a question
for you if the way I label things is
like set X6 and set X labels and the way
I set the col set CX that set label how
do you think we can label the y-
axis what do you think the method would
be called to label the y- axis
on how many you use not
Li okay so folks yeah what do you think
we use to label the Y
AIS yeah ax upset
[Music]
y okay X that's said y label what is our
y label
here
any and how do you think and what do you
think we we can do if we want want to
clear off the tips because we don't
really actually care that the 300
penguin if the method for the x
axis if the method for
the XEX is set X TI what do you think
the method is to clear the
YX yex um yep and it's set y to an empty
list
and again you can get F so we have these
out of the box methods like just setting
with numbers you can also get fan here
and use what I call our locator and
format objects found in the ticker
module and the locator objects let you
give you all kinds of tools for placing
the tix the format objects give you all
kinds of tools for how you want to write
the
tis because again the ticks are what
type of
object artist yeah um specifically
they're tick
objects um which means actually the tick
themselves you can do D tick do set and
you can t on H indidual on each
individual tick you can set its
properties
um which is also why take so long to PL
these
um okay so let's add another chart
so we have this really cool method
called subplot
MC
and it lets us do semantic chart organ
semantic figure composition which means
here like I can name my I can name my
axes and I can name and I can put them
in a list where I want them relative to
each other and when I do that I can um I
then have returns a dictionary of app of
the these objects that I can then
manipulate so here I'm just using it to
create a heat map and a scatter because
I don't want to lose track of these as
we keep going in this tutorial but where
it gets
fun is it can also do more complex
things like if you want one double wide
you can I mean you can pass in ratios as
arguments you can also just double up
the the heat map and if you double it up
you will get that if you double it up
it'll now be double wide if you want a
blank access in between you put a
dot um and this supports nesting so you
can build out these
complicated um compositions in list and
then Nest them inside of list I will say
again as things get more complicated
well we also have our subfigures
so you may want to sometimes use two or
three nested subfigures with each of
them having a complex artist
composition um rather than
nested so you may want to do that
instead of doing the
nested um subplot M kind of depending on
your needs um and the reason for this
goes down boils down to sub bigger
objects including subus other things you
can save out you cannot save out in
Access
give or
take um I say that give or take but I
think what really happens is you can
write an object that will either act on
a independent you can write a what the
real thing is that you actually have to
create a fig to save it out but you can
write a method that will act on the
figure and the subfigure and that's
identical so your fig creation method
that you do all your planning on you can
either pass in a figure that you can
then save out or you can pass in a
subfigure that's part of
bit
um
so so what I'm okay oh this was supposed
to be blank out of course it was um
let's pretend that's not
there how do you think we add another
quot type or another
axis yep add it to the
list we add
B so now I have space for three and how
do you all
think we add I totally skim through the
scatter plot didn't Ty okay sorry about
that
so we in this one we add a scatter again
the way this works is you add the
plotting method. scatter onto the axis
um you pass in the arguments scatter is
particularly one of those we can kind of
encode every variable so here we're
going to encode the length of the X and
the Y as the bill length and Bill depth
the size as the flipper length the color
as the cator categorical colors so here
we're just using that panas will Auto do
that conversion from categorical to a
codex cuz color doesn't take strings uh
color doesn't take categorical strings
it takes string
colors um
and then we here we're using the data
keyword um data equals DF and the
convenience of this using this keyword
is that it will do the dictionary
unpacking for you so if you want to
switch up your variables you can just
switch where the string are so what I
mean is how do you think if I want to
switch with on VX and Y how do you think
I should change
it
so what should this one be
then yeah and now we'll have our X and
our Y in a
different let's so now we flip which is
our X and our
y so that it's one of those kind of
quick ways or if you want to just kind
of keep switching through which what you
want to bought um into way to do that um
this SC Legend element is cuz here I
didn't explicitly name my colors right
like I didn't expit pass in labels to
tell you my colors so what I can do is I
can use this SC Legend elements function
to kind of gather this
info I it said GA the um Legend the info
you want to put in a legend like in this
case the colors it you can also use it
to grab the size because if you were
doing a scatter plot where each size dot
is a different Dot and then you can use
that Legend elements to make that to
make to build your
Legend um that we don't have both right
now okay so Bob and so this is what I
want to give you all like five 10
minutes to do to add a b chart
okay and I'll can walk around while we
do
that which I know the hello recording
recorded does not work so for this
but
oh and nobody's written in the hack and
yet please do write in there kind of
what you want to talk about and tell me
to cuz again very small group I may as
well what
up
yeah yeah yeah and as again as a Remer
the notebooks are all in the
we um I'm sorry what did you say like
where can I access the notebooks um
the my username 45p dataor nycore
2023 yeah so and after this tutorial
I'll clean that
up oh so yeah I can leave that also I
have the solution notebooks too yeah so
there and then to fold the
solutions
um
yeah
oh yeah we're on N1
static yeah yeah and I am sorry for so
much cut and paste here again function
ofuure
um
me at
120 so the Tut 12al and at 250
right
for
yeah and again if you whatever questions
you have you know please ask that's I'm
here I'm totally comfortable with this
being used half as of as hours if you
have map
questions
[Music]
that
um if you couldn't get code spaces to
work I will tell you that everything
should work in
collab um if you just need an
environment to um work in but now sorry
about that oh and actually what collab
will let you do is open a notebook from
GitHub so you can drop in url and open
the notebook that way to just follow
working on
them um so in this case like
I
um to
and right here
I just do this
actually
that's that will should open
it but yeah so you can like I said you
can just use collab to work also I will
say probably um Jupiter light
too and also the regular vs code um has
that follow so again the first two
notebooks one those three things should
work
um so how are folks
doing what
yeah
you're oh did you downlo file dat did
you download the file at
all is it
here okay which this says this says that
data plan
person I have
actually so download this um and drag
into folder into the
F and that should
look
[Music]
okay the question is is that where is
that Val to have
oh okay so a thing I'm sorry I haven't
taught in a couple of years so clearly
I'm Rusty um if you can't find the
folder what you can if you can't find
the data folder what you can do is PD
pd. read and you can put in the URL for
your file if you just put in the URL for
um data um if you click on p with CSV
and you do the URL you can load that
into the notebook you can pass in the
URL and it should
work I said that
of that's
too yeah I'm there used to be a way just
do
okay yeah the oh and H language is also
in SE point so you can get it that way
um but yeah just put it in the
fer
um okay how are folks doing
otherwise
wait
yes um
okay how you all
[Music]
doing so now you
need
um
this
so um is this
[Music]
open
um okay
[Music]
where this is all
to
[Music]
do you know where
this
can we find the full
path
you
yeah from
here
okay my timing is going to completely M
away from me if I don't come back here
so how are you all
feeling
um so if I want to add a ball chart how
should I add a b
chart
well what's the first thing I do to add
a b charart actually should go back how
many
folks
[Music]
um
okay how many um so who's who doesn't
have the data loaded
yet
okay okay um yeah so let's do this as a
pair
activity
um so we created a axis up here that we
named a b what do you think the plotting
method is for
ball that b so we can
do axt
do
scatter
axb and what should we plot there do we
know so if we don't know what a method
takes that's where we can go to
our um documentation and let's look up
The Ball Method the ball takes an X
position and a height so
for this Ty set what's our
X yeah we can do
what yeah the categorical give me the
species or if we've been doing our heat
map and we just want to like kind of do
some statistics on that what could our
categories be
yeah like the existing categor segmenta
they can also be and that that's kind of
what I've been using is the column
names right if we're plotting statistics
something columns and the column names
could be our X and what what what do we
want to F why what's an easy summary
statistic we might want bot about our
data
counts okay well we know I have counts
though do we know I counts I do we know
I have
counts yeah there's equal numbers of
each penguin type we sort of did that in
the first place what else you want to
know
average yeah let's do the average so the
first thing then we'll plot is we'll
plot the
categories
[Music]
um so map Li will let you pass in
categorical data which means we can plot
in pass in our categories directly As an
X and we
can and then we can subset our data
set and take the mean and that can be
our
y of course
nothing what in the
world
oh I
now oh
don't start changing things while you go
there okay tyos yeah so we now can pass
in out
mean and so we've got you know our three
link our three charts all showing
different views on the same data set
um what don't we like
here
color the bars how do you think we can
change
that so let's go to our
documentation let's go to bar and here
are all of the parameters height width
bottom align and then the other
parameters that are pass through to
again the underlying object in this case
bar is made up of these what what are
called patch objects which means that
the bar can take any argument that you
can pass through to the underlying
object and you will see this again all
over the place in M live of when we're
like you can pass
through um the other parameters or the
keywords of the passrs it's always a
pass through to the underlying um what
we call primitive artist object these
are kind of your standard your basic
visual marks your dot your line
your area your image so those got those
are kind of the
four core fundamental Primitives in M
live and the way they
are um phrased is that the dot are
What's called the path
collection um the line every line you
have to live is in line 2D object or
line
collection and
and every like area thing you see like a
bar Etc is what's called a path or a
patch object so those are our primitive
types
which again um I'm going to keep
stressing this because in visualization
things are either z d the dot 1D the
line 2D the
area or the heat map which is your image
which you can kind of say it's that but
we think of this a little bit
differently so this is the path
collection path
collection this is a line
Tod this is a
patch and this is an axis image and the
reason I'm going to keep stressing this
I say this there's also like qu um the
Contour stuff depending on what you're
going with but the reason I keep
stressing this is is because like when
you do a line plot that's underneath
that's what it's using it's using a line
object and so if you want to customize
things animate things make things
interactive that's the level you'll be
interacting with that plot at is the
things that make it
up the um and here so going to here to
customize the bars we can customize the
bars in any ways in which we can
customize our
patches so color
so let's change the color what color
should we change it
to
okay
okay what else what else we want to do
with color
here we can do yellow
okay now I'm going to have to spell too
and that's not already spell too so
you're getting
to
um and you see I'm passing in a list so
if you pass in a list of cuts equal to
the number of elements you're plotting
color each
sh and we have and that again like with
scatter that's what you're seeing that
like each do is sized and colored
according to its element um so lots of I
will let you do that
automatically and
so let's go to
animated so again we're going just start
a thing dat and actually like what's one
way we might want to animate this
I'm going to use the same code again and
the reason I use the same code for all
three of these is like I know this is
not the most compelling animation but my
goal here is that if we keep using the
same code it'll be easier to isolate
what is just the
addition
so we make our same base
chart um here that we know all too well
um all I did is I rearranged things just
to make them fit a little better
remember how I said Mosaic lets us kind
of move things around in a very custom
way so here I'm going to make the heat
map take up the entire right
side
um so same PL what's a thing you when
you have this kind of like length view
right because all three of these are
showing the same thing what might you
want to do with a length View
if you're building a dashboard or you're
doing a scientific paper and you have
three charts and they're showing kind of
different aspects of the same thing what
might be a thing that you really want to
be able to
show moving into place the elements
moving into place or like the individual
elements right okay
oh this is a list of penguins those dots
each present the penguin this is the
mean of all the Penguins what might I
want to know about this one and the ball
charart the heat map and the
scatter and I'm sorry I end up bias this
side but you all same question um what
might I want to know between the Heat
Map and the ball chart and the scatter
PL
here
[Music]
something like that but like say I have
um one penguin here like what's our
pengu with's
name Jo
Joe okay Joe is number 150 here what
what I want to know about Joe in the
scatter
pot stats well what's the good thing do
I know what Joe is in there do I maybe
want to find
out and do I want to know any stop right
to have a bar CH to do I want to know
maybe how Joe
Compares
so so yes so let it let us plot Joe and
so that's what we're doing here in the
next it we are plotting jokes
so again the same base we do not change
like but we're going to make our heat
map we're going to make our Matrix our
heat map we're going to make our scatter
plot and we're going to make
our power chart and then we're going to
layer cuz again if you want to add
things to an out to an axis you just
plot on top of the axis map is fine with
like you can have a l chart and the bar
chart and the scatter chart and whatever
else you want on the same chart as long
as they all are on the same coordinate
system and the truth is you can plant
them with the non coordinate system
you're just going to get a very wonky
chart um so with the assumption that
you're plotting in the same coordinate
system you can put and I say this
because the other thing you can do and
for advanced users is you can add a
second scale to the same chart so if I
wanted to I could plot like Fahrenheit
and Celsius on the same chart where
Fahrenheit is on the left and Celsius on
the
right
so that's yeah but so here we plot and
so what we're going to do is the first
thing we're going to do is we're going
to grab one random penguin let's we're
going to find Joe Joe is a random number
in that
dat
um and we're going to Joe on the heat
map what we do
is we
plot we add here to the heat map a
horizontal line at Joe's
position so that's
Joe so how do you think we can then
Circle Joe on find Joe on the scatter
plot what do we want to do to the
scatter plot to find
Joe yeah
so we go to the
scatter what do we how do we what do we
plot to find to a
scatter do scattered now here's a cheat
sheet the only thing that changes is Joe
right so what you can do is you can use
all of the same long code we've already
done
here um
um the only thing we need to change is
we need to now we're going to have to
find we're going to have to actually
find out Joe species to get him the
right
code and we can change the data if we
change the data that feeds this we can
just do joke and we don't have to change
any of the rest of that code again
except that so what do you think so what
do you think the data is here if we want
to just PL
your Penguins yeah
and here actually let's let's just make
this thing about circling Joe so we
don't have to worry about a color for a
second um it's a little bit tricky here
because of how because I'm using cat
codes and stuff but
so
um and of course this is why you doic
okay yeah
so what we did is we change the data set
to
penguin and I'm going to change the edge
color to red and I'm going to change the
line width to two so we can very much
see
him and that's
[Applause]
Joe